hello everyone and welcome to Alp 307
the public policy lab Financial
challenges facing U.S cities at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business I'm
Professor Josh Rao and today we're
thrilled to be hosting three expert
panelists to discuss economic
development in cities across the U.S Dr
Tim bartick Dr Becky Lester and Dr David
Newmark I'm also grateful to the
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
the Hoover Institution for supporting
this webinar
so today's topic
is building cities for the future
as we know governments use a range of
different policies to boost their local
economies and promote growth and
innovation in particular economic
developers very frequently make use of
tools like tax incentives and abatements
and exemptions to attract new firms to
their cities and retain existing
businesses and also increasingly use
other incentives such as Innovation hubs
manufacturing hubs and the promise of a
supply of skilled workers for firms who
locate in the city
while billions and billions of dollars
are spent by local governments on
economic development each year the
overall impact of this investment is in
fact uncertain
let me provide a little bit of
background on our course for our viewers
this is an experiential learning class
in which we've partnered with three
cities across the country each a
different size in a different region and
with different economic and political
landscapes we have three work streams on
which student groups are working to
assess City policies conduct research
and make data driven and evidence-based
policy recommendations those areas are
infrastructure dead in pensions and of
course the topic of our webinar today
Economic Development over the past few
weeks we've met with city managers
economic developers commissioners of
Public Works and many other local
government officials to learn more about
what challenges these cities are facing
and what keeps City officials up at
night
so now we want to hear from the subject
matter experts the goal of the webinar
today is to learn what academic research
tells us about economic development in
cities across the U.S how effective are
tax incentives in attracting companies
can the benefits of attracting and
retaining companies offset the costs and
how should cities plan for the future
today's panel should help us answer
these difficult questions but first let
me give a few introductions
Dr Tim bartick is a senior Economist at
the we Option Institute for employment
research and the co-editor of Economic
Development quarterly welcome Tim
uh thank you for having me
Dr Becky Lester is an associate
professor of accounting and a both a
Chan faculty scholar at Stanford GSB
she's also a research fellow at the
Stanford Institute for economic policy
research and at the Hoover institution
welcome Becky thank you
and finally Dr David Newmark is a
distinguished professor of Economics at
the University of California Irvine and
co-director at the center for population
inequality and policy at UC Irvine he is
also a research fellow at The Institute
of labor economics welcome David
thanks
so I'd like to begin with just some
kickoff remarks by each of our panelists
today who will speak with us for a few
minutes about what some of the main
conclusions are about the use of
Economic Development Tools in cities in
the U.S from their research so I'm going
to begin with Dr Tim bartick Tim
well I guess some of the things I would
emphasize at the outset is that Economic
Development policies such as incentives
uh
have much higher costs than are commonly
realized but also can have high benefits
which is why they're attractive now
the costs are higher than I commonly
realized because contrary to what some
State Economic Development officials
like to assume uh not every firm you
touch with an incentive is magically
induced to locate because of the
incentive that a lot of these jobs would
have occurred anyway the company would
have located there anyway or if that
company didn't choose that site some
other comedy would have chosen the site
later on maybe in the near future so the
cost per job is actually much higher
than uh often is assumed by just looking
at how many jobs have been incented on
the other hand the benefits can also be
high and that's because jobs can be very
valuable to
um local areas and the value sometimes
you'll see analyzes uh done by states
and cities that focused on the revenue
generation in other words that look on
economic development programs as if
they're a way to make money for the city
and what that overlooks first of all is
the fact that in some cases the
incentives don't induce activity and
they're all cost and don't actually
increase tax revenue the other thing
they Overlook is that when you attract
jobs you attract people
and people are costly you have to hire
teachers you have to improve the
infrastructure uh and once you account
for that the fiscal benefits of these
frequently are quite low that it's not a
way to make money for a state or city
what it might be is a way to increase
employment opportunities
and there's a lot of evidence that local
job growth can have very persistent
effects on employment to population
ratios and real earnings per capita of
local residents
but in order for that to occur you have
to increase employment rates and that's
going to vary with whether or not the
area is distressed or not
if there are air is already booming you
can only go so far in increasing
employment rates it depends on the types
of jobs can local residents access them
realistically given their skills given
the types of jobs do the jobs actually
offer some wage premium over jobs that
would have been available anyway
do they pay well compared to the
credentials required and finally of
course public policy can affect this in
the sense that there's not some iron law
as to who gets the jobs when jobs are
created by Economic Development policies
maybe we can get to that later on but
the key thing I want to emphasize is I
look on economic development policies as
being a subtype of local labor market
policy it's a subtype that works
primarily on the labor demand side but
has to also be concerned with how the
labor supply side reacts to that let me
stop there and I'll and we can get into
more questions
okay thank you very much Tim next up for
some introductory remarks is Dr Becky
Lester Becky
great thanks so much I actually have
just a couple of short slides I'd like
to go through
um let me share my screen here
okay
um all right so I'm just going to talk a
little bit about how I approach this
question and then we'll come back to the
kind of what my two main conclusions are
at this point in time so you know the
way I think about the tax system as a
tax accountant is typically we think
about it as something that would take
just takes away revenue or takes away
money from individuals or from companies
days but could we instead actually start
thinking about the tax system as an
economic development tool and I think
that's really important for
understanding and thinking about
incentives and how they can or cannot be
so in particular if we think about
um trying to use it as a tool we need to
optimize things in terms of you know
which type of system would most
efficiently motivate companies to invest
in hire workers contribute to Local
Economic Development and ultimately
provide the highest return on the
taxpayer dollars that are used to give
to give those tools
um well I thought experiment here so
let's let's think about two different
extremes of a tax system one which is
where you have a state or a locality
that provides really really low tax
rates that apply to every company's
every company that locates in that area
and so that could be very attractive
because the overall tax burden is quite
low and it could be quite a an easy
system to administer on the other hand
think about a system that maybe has
higher rates just in order to generate
sufficient Revenue but then provides
targeted incentives at a certain number
of companies and the benefit of that is
that it introduces discretion into a
policy Maker's toolkit so they're
allowed to actually Target the
incentives at the type of companies they
may want to attract to an area now most
systems are somewhere in between these
two but I think it's interesting to
approach this question from from this
perspective of kind of thinking about
two different extremes so kind of what
do we know what do we know from the
economic research that's been conducted
what a very very high level we know
certainly that low tax rates attract
companies and employees and this is some
work that Josh has done and also some
work that Tim has done with some other
economy and some other economists as
well is saying that yeah that we know
these rates attract companies but
actually we also observe that incentives
are very very broadly used in the
economy so much show that they're
expected to almost reduce corporate
revenues that come in corporate tax
revenues by almost 40 percent
so you know why why are they used what's
the importance of them well when we talk
to economic developers or when I've had
conversations with them they say that
these these incentives are critical
they're almost important or necessary to
compete and a lot of that's because
everybody else is using them so if they
don't use the incentives then they're
just going to lose out on on the jobs
that they are trying to create
so if we take a step back then the
question is kind of what's the overall
impact of these incentives and frankly I
would say the my read of the the
evidence is pretty mixed
um and you know sometimes incentives
seem to create jobs other times they do
not seem to have local effects and then
there's all the other issues that that
um that Tim brought up a minute ago
which is about the additional cost Etc
well when I look at the evidence I think
one of the reasons that we might have
some pretty mixed evidence on this is
due to incomplete data so this is going
to lead me into kind of two key
conclusions
um or what I what I think of of what of
what incentives are at this moment so
just bear with me for a minute I wanted
to show you a little bit about what I
mean about the incomplete data that
we're trying to base some of our studies
on so this is a map that some
researchers will use as a map from one
of my other papers which is using data
from good jobs first this is a
not-for-profit that tries to track
incentives and what you see are like the
27 States in blue are states where like
the the data are so poor that our
researcher can't even use them they just
it's it's clearly wrong and the other
states is kind of this Patchwork of
where there are some data there is some
information but it's quite difficult to
actually you know piece together
everything that's happening because the
information varies a lot across time and
a lot across jurisdictions
so I think when we come back to this
question of like how do we think about
taxes as an economic development tool
um there's really this kind of challenge
when thinking about incentives it's
pretty difficult to I think fully assess
them and fully think about when can they
be most effective versus not
um because of this data problem that's
really precluding a lot of
um you know additional research from
happening to inform that question so
I've done work in the two areas that I
think actually are the biggest challenge
here and clearly in my opinion the two
of the biggest areas or challenges
um the first one is actually trying to
get better data on how prevalent
incentives are so I think we really need
to understand how prevalent they are in
order to really assess the designer use
of them and so this is some work
actually with Josh
um with the state of Alabama and with a
lot of localities where we're physically
driving and going and meeting with
economic developers and counties asking
them to share their data with us so that
we can actually comment on the
prevalence of the incentives and add
that into the discussion and add that
into the analysis
and the related Point here is that just
generally there's a lack of disclosure
and transparency around the incentives
that are given and I think that really
precludes a lot more researchers or
other researchers from trying to
understand what's happening because we
just we can't see what's occurring and
if we can't see it certainly the the
broader public can't see it either so
let me I'm going to wrap up here with
just giving you two specific examples
um from these two different kind of
goals or areas of research that I do so
the first one is just trying to
understand kind of what's really
happening how much are we really how
much are state and local governments
really giving to companies
um it's a lot so I'm just going to show
you an example using data from three
Alabama counties what we see is that in
an eight year period over 280 local
incentives are given so not even
including the state incentives and total
these are pretty big so 316 million
awarded to around 77 companies and
what's really important is that 100
percent of those incentives are totally
missing from the common data sets that a
researcher might use and just as a
picture what you see here are incentives
Broken Out by type but you see that
these are all incentives under the
jurisdiction of a city or a county
official and the amount of those in
total is increasing over time and you
see variation based on if they're giving
a property tax abatement or sales and
use Etc so I think this is just one step
forward to show that we need a lot more
evidence around the local incentives to
truly assess the local and state
incentives to assess the design
and then the the second thing I'll I'll
uh comment on and then wrap up is this
trend this idea of transparency and
disclosure so a lot of states are moving
towards passing more laws around trying
to provide some type of information
about who the public dollars go to
States give away a lot of money for
these incentives and I think
increasingly there are calls for more
information around them so good jobs
first this is their favorite saying
which is sunshine is the best antiseptic
and and assuming that the public is kind
of a good monitor whether or not that's
true I think remains to be seen but this
idea that there should just be more open
disclosure around it one example that
this is a screenshot from Virginia where
they have their own uh this is an
example of a portal if you go to
Virginia you can see a list of company
names
um you know date that an incentive was
given the type of incentive Etc and more
and more states are doing this but this
is really not done at all I think at the
local level
so what I find so far is that or in my
research in this is that this does seem
to help um with the effectiveness of
incentives having more information
around
um that seems to actually be a mechanism
to force governments or Force companies
to to follow through more on their
objectives but what we find is that that
conclusion is a little bit nuanced so
actually once the public disclosure
happens we see some governments actually
like substitute away they start swapping
the type of incentives they give because
they would prefer to give incentives
that they don't have to publicly report
and we also see governments kind of
post-sale data so while a disclosure
regime might be helpful in general if
governments aren't actually posting all
the information or they're not you know
their feed aren't held to the fire to
keep it up to date it's not clear that
these regimes will be that helpful
um so I think there's a lot more
questions here but the biggest
conclusions I have so far is that I
think incentives can be helpful and
useful but we don't really have a good
sense of how prevalent incentives are
and then consequently it's hard to
understand
um which ones are most effective and I
think
um you know transparency is one way of
trying to understand and see what what
governments are really spending the
question that I would leave you with is
this last one on this page which we've
talked about the first three here but is
um you know ultimately will there have
to be some type of like a multi-state or
multilateral uh solution or agreement
across states to kind of agreed and not
giving incentives
um I don't know this is happening on the
international stage with very very mixed
results and a lot of skepticism but as
long as States kind of continue to
compete for activity with incentives it
seems like we're going to have a lot
more spending without a lot of clear
results
okay thank you very much
thank you very much Becky and finally
turning to Dr David Newmark for some
introductory remarks David thanks you
got my slides up see him great okay I'm
starting my five minute timer
um this is great uh you know sometimes
when you hear you're gonna hear about
the the academic evidence on a policy
question the evidence is pretty
disconnected from policy but in this
case
um this evidence is all very close to
policy so I'm going to talk about some
local job creation policies uh some
general issues but use examples from my
research
um I was going to call this it was the
best of local development policies it
was the worst of local development
policies but that's a really long title
so this is a shorter version
um let me just um
start with the problem when you're
trying to create incentives
to encourage firms to create jobs we
should never say that governments don't
really create jobs unless they hire
people directly but incentives for job
creation so the primary goal and Tim
alluded to this is to incentivize the
job creation
um as opposed to doing things that maybe
put money in the hands of firms but
don't actually create jobs uh I would
say and we can come back to this later I
have a pretty strong view that real
estate subsidies are not the way to do
this uh but that's a that's sort of a
separate issue but there's many
challenges even if you decide we're
going to go after job creation
incentives directly you have to reward
the changes that would have occurred
that would that would have occurred only
because of the incentive not the changes
that would have occurred absolutely
incentive but if you think about it that
can be a hard thing to design right if
payroll grows I don't know if it would
have happened otherwise right but we
don't want to pay for the behavior that
would have happened otherwise we call
those windfalls and there could be some
windfalls uh but we don't want it to be
all when false
um you if you if you say oh let's do new
hiring
um only well then companies might churn
their workers uh and there's some
evidence uh that that they do that the
more you try to Target the incentive as
well and be clever about that the more
you might raise administrative costs
which can sort of lead to the whole
thing not being attracted to firms
um when you target incentives excuse me
based on worker characteristics and many
incentives do some form of disadvantage
while they Define there's the potential
issue of stigmatizing them a worker has
to sort of show that they're eligible it
might also show something that signals
to the firm maybe that are less
interested in hiring them
um I think you want to create even if
jobs are being created
we might be okay with jobs moving from
one location to another but in general I
think and policy makers seem to agree
we're happier with policies that create
new jobs not that move jobs around
especially within the same jurisdiction
that's paying for them that's
particularly wasteful one state might be
happy to steal jobs from another state
uh so let me give you some examples of
things that work well on things that
work badly and there's a handbook
chapter I mentioned here I assume these
slides will be available to you uh which
goes through a lot of this in a lot of
detail uh so Enterprise zones Enterprise
zones were sort of the granddaddy I
think of Local Economic Development
incentives uh for a long time we still
have some federal programs and some
State programs I did work on the
California Enterprise Zone Program I
think the most studied State program
probably uh there's an absence of clear
evidence that these things have created
jobs uh or raised incomes or raised
incomes for low-income residents take
your take your it's almost impossible to
find a Criterion on which they've been
successful Federal programs have been
more successful it seems like based on
some evidence um from Bruce
um
uh but you have this dilemma that the
benefits don't seem to be going to the
low-income residents of targeted places
raises a whole another question some
people hear local development they say
gentrification bad stop the train uh
some people are a little more subtle and
say well we want some gentrification but
maybe we need to think about how it
happens
um the California program had
particularly lousy design features
credit was paid for any new hire among
those who are qualified
and that was based on Target on
individual characteristics or where you
lived or close to where you lived
um wasn't really trying to figure out in
any way hiring created because of the
incentive and the biggest problem I
think the credits could be paid
retroactively or these tax advisory
firms found a big business in helping
you claim your credit from up to three
years ago well if you're doing that it's
probably not creating jobs it's just
nice nice gravy for businesses
um latest incarnation of a program that
I think works badly is opportunity zones
I don't know if you've talked about them
in your class these are more more real
estate focused these are basically I'll
go into detail um but essentially
capital gains tax breaks for investment
in in real estate uh in lower income
communities
um uh Governors could designate areas
based on certain criteria uh the bottom
line as far as we can tell some other
papers now coming out with consistent
evidence uh residents at least are not
helped
um uh it's it's not clear these are
doing much of anything uh opportunity
zones also I think have really poor
design features in my opinion targeting
real estate investment is not the way to
go if you want to Target jobs it's still
tough but Target jobs there's also
particular problems with opportunity
zones and this goes to some of what
Becky was talking about it's very
non-transparent first of all to claim an
opportunity's own tax credit on your tax
return uh you don't even have to you
just there's no documentation you just
claim it uh it's been very hard to get
data on where these Investments are
being claimed where they're going
anything like that and finally I just
I'll just sort of flip the table a bit
I've been studying the last few years
this program which California put in
place when it killed the Enterprise Zone
Program uh called the California
competes tax credit
um this I sort of couldn't believe it
when I heard what they were doing
um uh but they they build in a lot of
the best practices and they did some of
this data deliberately and some of this
they did accidentally
um they have explicit eligibility
thresholds based on kind of what you're
asking for versus what your promise
you're going to do
um and then there's some discretion on
the part of program officials where
Becky talked about which I think I think
Tim has some older work I think also
suggesting this is quite important
um
uh and uh and then they have this sort
of structure built in which which lends
itself to very rigorous empirical
investigation I think that was The
Accidental part they also good design
feature they have very clear goals
they're specified up to over five years
and you have to maintain the jobs for
another three years beyond that or they
claw back or recapture the credits and
we have evidence they do we worked with
the gov the governor's office of
business Economic Development
a lot of interviewing and talking to
them and getting all their data most
importantly
um uh we could match that to census
level establishment level data we could
actually see the recapture of tax
credits that's actually public
information uh We've two papers one
showing when you look at kind of
location uh there's strong multipliers
from this and the tracks where these
things are awarded and then we have a
firm level data set which really takes
advantage of the structure the structure
of the program which finds a pretty
strong job growth effects and as I said
I think this is due to good design
features so my evolving perspective and
then I'll stop before I got to cctc I
was pretty skeptical my handbook chapter
of your reading is pretty negative
um I think justifiably most prior
evidence fail to find beneficial effects
a lot of the time because poor design
was sort of baked into the programs for
one reason or another the cctc shows
that you can design programs better they
have it seems to be working uh I will
one important caveat the people who run
it and make the decisions we've sat in
their office and watched them at work
they're really good at what they do uh
can that be replicated everywhere I
don't know can it even be replicated in
California if those people turn over I
don't know that either but design seems
to matter
stop there thank you
thank you very much David these have
been some great introductory remarks and
uh I'm going to start out with with a
few questions on my end and uh we'll
have some discussion and then we'll turn
it over to uh students to ask some
questions
so one of the things that comes through
in a lot of the research is that a lot
of these business incentives are rather
wasteful you hear the term corporate
welfare a lot and it doesn't seem to be
that far off the mark incentives are by
and large not that effective at
promoting job growth but states and
cities are really
enamored of their Economic Development
initiatives so practically you know what
what do we tell them and you know this
goes to to what some of Dave was
presenting there are a lot of bad ideas
that we see out there uh you know these
retroactive credits or you know no doc
necessary or a credit paid for any new
hire without any any specifications and
there's some good ideas that you've
clearly been able to identify through
the the California competes tax credit
and so on so I guess I guess two two
questions for for the group number one
practically you know what do you what do
you tell a a city or an economic
development Authority that's that's
looking to improve and and secondly are
there other success stories uh of of
local governments in particular who have
uh in the words of Tim's book on a more
nutritional diet so to speak as far as
incentives are concerned
well I don't know who stood order we're
going in but I guess what I would say is
that it's better to try to reform
incentives than eliminate them because
uh in fact incentives are politically
popular Governors and Mayors who do them
get reelected uh people in the U.S are
understandably concerned about jobs and
employment opportunities and saying
you're not going to try to intervene to
affect that is not really politically
feasible so I would say first of all you
need to provide some alternatives to
incentives that might be more cost
effective so I push things like
customized job training I've pushed
doing things with uh business sites
infrastructure trying to do uh
industrial parks research Parks
high-tech Parks business incubators and
I push business advice programs such as
manufacturing extension and there are
places that have pursued those very
actively it has success with them so I
live about an hour south of Grand Rapids
Michigan
and Grand Rapids is perhaps the most
successful
manufacturing intensive City mid-sized
city in the U.S it's had manufacturing
job growth over the last 30 years which
is remarkable given the overall U.S
pattern with the China shock and
whatever now some of that is incentives
but a lot of it is they got a regional
office of the manufacturing extension
service there
they really worked extensively with
clusters of business on trying to work
local community college and setting up
training programs that met their needs
they tried to see if they could find uh
local buyers for a family-owned smaller
firms that might be otherwise sold off
to some multinational which does affect
investment decisions and how they're
made realistically if you look at it
um and uh you know they've also done
some things with real estate development
Land Development they got Michigan State
to put a large part of his medical
school there they've done some things in
health research and so as an example
they've helped some say some Auto
suppliers who were bending metal and
molding plastic for Autos to diversify
into medical instruments
which also use metal and plastic but
maybe as a more rapidly growing market
now you might say well how can't
businesses do this on their own well if
you're a small medium-sized manufacturer
is trying to figure out how to Pivot to
a dramatically different Market with
very different
regulatory structure different ways in
which you find customers is not
necessarily straightforward so I think
you need to give Alternatives and not
just say well we're just going to let
the market rip and whatever happens to
jobs
uh happens and then I think when we get
the actual incentives we need to give
Alternatives there as well I mean what
I've said in the past
is why on Earth are you handing out
15-year attacks abatements
or a 15-year wage credits
who really thinks that companies are
making location decisions based on the
magnitude of the abatement in the year
13.
now there are reasons Mayors and
governors do this namely they're giving
away the next mayor's tax base
but it's too tempting to do it it
creates long-term fiscal problems so I
would say you know let's have a term of
say five years at Max and let's have
maybe let's make them more upfront with
a clawback you know I kind of like
Virginia's approach to incentives
Virginia for Amazon
um headquarters 2 which located in DC
suburbs that their incentive was twenty
two thousand dollar payment per job
and it's credited to the company right
away but the company can't access it for
four years
the job has to still be around in four
years so it's up front but it also has a
delay it's an easier way of doing a
clawback uh and uh you know I think that
the Virginia's approach and of course
Virginia also combined the incentive
with the the they're putting a branch of
uh Virginia Virginia Tech there and
they're they're doing a bunch of stuff
with job training and infrastructure and
improving the metro station around there
or whatever so I think they did more
than just hand out cash so in general my
advice is
look for Alternatives such as various
business services that enhance
productivity and if you're doing
incentives try to make them more upfront
and a little more targeted so
Becky anything to add there yeah so one
of them is exactly what Tim was talking
about which is shifting from this
shifting from just giving cash
incentives so my impression is that
um you call it 20 years ago and probably
even still today in many places it's
just like what we're going to give you a
bundle of cash if you come here and
there's very little reporting required
after the fact very little follow-up and
in my my understanding is very few
callbacks so there should be callbacks
but it's not obvious that they occurred
if they occur they're probably
infrequent so I think shifting away from
just giving cash incentives just like
Tim is talking about trying to make them
um you know an incentive show up
actually when a company be able to claim
an incentive if they can actually
approve jobs were created after the fact
as opposed to just giving them some cash
up front I think is a step a huge step
in the right direction along with all of
these things he's mentioning too like
thinking about
um making investments in the local area
and the property and infrastructure and
things that maybe could benefit the
broader area not just specific company
so one is Shifting the type of incentive
and then the second thing is again I'm
going to come back to this question of
reporting and disclosure which is
um you know requiring a company to act
in this in this setting would be
requiring a company to actually report
back to the city and county about what
they've done on an annual basis
requiring them to actually provide
evidence that they have created these
jobs and if those are not if they don't
come through then then having some
callback mechanism in place now
certainly that's more administrative
hassle but if these are given on the
basis of actually creating jobs or a
certain amount of capital investment it
seems very reasonable to ask for some
type of reporting within the government
and then some monetary mechanism later
it's not simple but I think it's a
pretty important one and and also would
help the localities understand how much
has happened I mean one of the things in
our conversations with local developers
is that they really don't have kind of a
uh you know an after the fact assessment
of how many jobs they think you know
often will will have an estimate of it
but
um very few you know a lot of times the
incentives are given based on a promise
up front and understanding what really
happens on the back end is something
that I think is an open question that
many many really want to know the answer
to so it's some type of reporting
mechanism might help them get a little
bit closer to knowing those answers
yes great and David has just actually
posted in uh in the chat a link to
something he wrote about a new possible
place-based policy approach rebuilding
communities job subsidies David you want
to say a few words about that yeah it
will make three really quick points
first of all
um I I think uh you know you all hit on
this um and I know Josh you have in your
in your pension and debtstop right that
you know people in office are there
typically for limited periods and
delivering some goodies would sound like
goodies and paying the cost later
um doesn't doesn't really bother them
it's a perfectly rational behavior
um I think what that leads to and I
think the reason you know the reason
someone happened in Grand Rapids doesn't
happen elsewhere is because you know
with Americans say this company's coming
here that's sexy when they say yeah yeah
we're building up the community college
program and you know
um in some new area which you think
companies can pivot to not nearly as
sexy Mike Tim was out here a couple
weeks ago we were talking about Grand
Rapids my guess is what's going on in
Grand Rapids is you also have a very
rich and powerful company that has a
rich and Powerful family I should say
that has a much longer term interest in
the city than any mayoral terms I could
be wrong about that um but maybe the
externalities are captured a little more
because of that
um I do think to this point the kind of
transparency stuff Becky's talking about
makes sense at least the public should
know what they're paying and ideally
also you know harder to answer uh what
they're getting um to at least hold hold
the elected officials feet to the fire a
little more I'm also with Tim on I don't
know I don't adopt the view I just scrap
this all because a lot of it doesn't
work
um I think improvement's important the
thing I posted in the chat is a
something I wrote for Brookings I'm
going to the details and now you can
read it but
it was really saying we still have to
keep thinking about this but maybe we
have to think about it in a really
targeted way because we have severe
social problems in cities that come from
extremely poor neighborhoods and I was
trying in this in that piece to based on
what we know not evaluating programs in
existence how would I design a program
what kind of features would I build in
that might actually start to deliver
benefits at the very local level to
extremely disadvantaged neighborhoods I
view that as in some sense
the fundamental challenge that we have
to wrestle with
something I didn't hear quickly that I
do think it's important at some point
and this may be very important for what
you're doing with this class uh when we
talk about targeting places within setas
and that this came up when uh David and
I had this dialogue at Journal policy
analysis and management
um there are programs that try to Target
uh local labor markets
that might be distressed and a lot of
state and local Economic Development
policies are in that direction uh that
they're trying to increase overall job
growth in the state or in some metro
area or whatever and and and the cities
that you talk to a city they're usually
part of some Metro
uh there's usually some kind of Metro
Economic Development effort with some
kind of coordination and there's some
partnership with the state then there's
the issue of neighborhoods and what we
need to realize is neighborhoods are not
labor markets
uh local labor markets are local labor
markets most Americans don't live and
work in the same neighborhood most jobs
in the neighborhood don't go to
Neighborhood residents most residents
from neighborhood don't work in the
neighborhood so one thing you need to
recognize is the problem of helping deal
with lack of jobs in a distressed
neighborhood is fundamentally different
from dealing with the lack of jobs
overall the local labor market needs a
different solution and in fact at the
neighborhood level I think you need to
work more on the labor supply side uh
frankly and and think about Solutions
there but linking up with the labor
demand side so a totally different type
of problem that's that's the problem I
would say with opportunity zones and
Enterprise zones it's not really the
right tool for that problem frankly that
was one of the directions speaking of
Labor Supply that I I wanted to bring
our discussion into one of the issues
that some of our partner cities are
experiencing is a lack of supply of the
employees potential employees with the
right skill set a mismatch between the
skill set or educational level of the
the city's possible Workforce compared
with the skills that the high-paying
jobs that they're hoping to attract
would require and so I I wanted to ask
everyone how should economic developers
think about Workforce Development and
are there any Innovative approaches
you've seen cities taking taking or that
they could take to better match their
existing labor force with the necessary
skills that are being demanded by the
companies that they're seeking to
attract
well I would say they need to do is
first of all I'm a big fan of customized
job training programs which are
typically where community colleges work
with companies to provide training
programs to the company's needs
especially if the if their new jobs or
expansion and as part of that the
customized training program can help
expand the hiring pool the company
beyond what they might hire on their own
um you so you I think that's a great
approach it's more feasible than Pro
than doing hiring quotas which you can
do in some cases but obviously if you're
trying to track companies the carrot
might work better than the stick
um you know I also think you need to
think about uh uh in the case of
neighborhoods uh the afternoon Institute
where I work in addition to having
researchers like me has an Operations
Division that that coordinates job
training programs in the Four County
area around Kalamazoo and the Kellogg
Foundation has funded us to run
neighborhood employment hubs in
distressed neighborhoods of Battle Creek
and that essentially is trying to get
the job training programs out of
downtown Office Buildings into the
neighborhood and to have
basically help they're located at
churches in the neighborhood they're
located at subsidized housing projects
there's one at the jail there's one at a
Community Action Agency in the
neighborhood and these are trusted
neighboring institutions so people are
more willing to show up there than they
might be at some in personal office
building downtown and then you can
actually help coordinate how do we help
you find child care what what job
openings are there what what job
training programs are there can we get
you a reliable used car and then you can
also we run some programs with success
coaches that help people retain jobs in
other words they work with companies to
help deal with problems that impede job
retention so I think in addition to
thinking about these incentives which
are trying to work directly in the labor
demand side we need to think about Labor
Supply approaches that actually Reach
people in the neighborhoods we're trying
to reach and connect them up with jobs
we don't have enough what in the
European context they call active labor
market programs we really don't have
that in the U.S at a large scale
and I add a couple things into that as
well so
um in some of our discussions with Local
Economic developers three things they
say are the biggest direction to
actually getting people into the labor
force so in an environment where the
unemployment rate is very low it becomes
very important to actually try to get
more people in the labor force to fill
all these jobs that incentives have
created and so just like Tim is saying
like the the frictions that we hear are
three-fold Child Care Transportation and
now with housing prices to some extent
also Workforce housing especially in
rural communities like trying to get a
big company into an area
um may be attractive because the you
know costs are low and things like that
but if there's not a sufficient housing
base there for people to actually move
to or live in or even just quality
housing that's a real friction for
actually getting people to fill those
jobs so I think those are the three
things in addition to Workforce training
those are the three things that
um I think are very critical for or an
economic developer to try to think about
and they're not in the business of
operating child care facilities in some
places like in Alabama public
transportation comes with very negative
connotation and so running you know the
public transportation probably isn't
isn't sufficiently broad or go where it
needs to go but it also comes with a lot
of understandably negative stigma and so
trying to solve problems like child care
and transportation and I think
increasingly some type of Workforce
housing are really going to be important
in terms of getting more people into the
labor force to try to work work the jobs
that were created by the incentives
I'll just I'll just second what Tim the
first thing Tim said about community
colleges I think there's I think there's
evidence bears by state
um that community colleges
like it's not surprising for those of us
at non-community colleges are much more
attuned to the local labor market partly
because of their mission partly because
they often have you know non-full-time
non-tenure streaming faculty who are who
work in Industry teaching
um uh so so that's a that's a really
useful tool I think two two caveats one
is states have to fund them the right
way I know California for example we
have a good extensive community college
system but the funding is the same no
matter what you're studying and it's a
lot cheaper to run an English class than
a nursing class or you know some health
technology class because there's no
technology involved
um so I think it takes not just saying
we need community colleges and they have
to be strong but they kind of need the
funding to support ramping up to provide
technical skills uh the second is I
think there's still there's still this a
problem in me you know maybe maybe the
things Tim has spoken about at up John
have solved this of you know these work
for younger people right who are
entering the labor market don't have
high wages yet so opportunity costs are
low don't have a mortgage may not have
kids
um the problem is you know we we know
there's a problem of low employment
among most skilled much older men for
example uh are they really gonna go back
to school are they really going to roll
in a training program but obviously
they're part of the potential labor
Supply pool and given how much their
employment has decreased there's at
least in principle room for increase uh
and I think that's a challenge that a
lot at least the Community College
institutions
aren't aren't that well geared for
there's some older students but maybe
other programs that really reach them
and maybe take on the expense of
supporting them to replace the income
from their crappy job while they train
for a better job might be necessary
that's of course one area where we've
seen as you're mentioning you know
really weak weak labor force
participation is uh uh you know among
among middle middle-aged men and there's
there's been a big decline there and so
I think asking the question of what can
these institutions do to try to bring
some of those people back into labor
force with the right skills is really
important another observation it you
know it seems to me that some of the
solutions that um that have been
outlined here and that some Innovative
places are undertaking require really
good coordination of different
government agencies with each other and
and and you know sometimes I have the
feeling that proposing these things to
people that we're speaking to uh or
might speak to they might say well this
is a great idea but you know we have to
bring together all of these different
entities and I you know that's that's
maybe more of a political problem than
an economic problem or you know this is
a group primarily of economists but I I
was wondering if anyone any had any
thoughts or comments about about that
but that practical challenge as well
well a lot of times I can active old
agencies when you actually look at how
economic development is organized in the
U.S first you have the state Economic
Development agencies and then of course
at the local level of those cities
particularly large cities may have
Economic Development frequently you do
have some kind of Metro
uh a private uh non-profit organization
that operates and that works with the
local governments as and they do
recruitment they work with existing
business
uh and they're usually a multi-county
Authority I mean Grand Rapids I
mentioned already Michigan has the right
place program which is a multi-county
program uh you know right around
Kalamazoo there's Southwest Michigan
First which operates uh in Kalamazoo and
one at least one or two surrounding
counties
uh Battle Creek has Battle Creek
unlimited which operates county-wide so
typically the economic development
organizations that do a lot of the
recruiting and business expansion and
trying to get business Parks started up
and that kind of thing is something that
is not actually the city government may
help fund it and help influence it
and help make some of the money
available because economic developers
frequently don't have the funds
available but I actually do think that
you need to run these things more on a
local labor market basis not on a
individual jurisdiction basis the way
local governments are organized the U.S
is not logical from an economic point of
view
yeah the only thing I would add is
um I think
the the the other way that lack of
coordination gets manifested is you just
get sort of you know idea flavor of the
month policies adopted uh and without a
lot of thinking about how they fit how
they work and fit together uh I see that
at the state level in California I'm
doing this inventory of kind of all
policies that you could at least have at
least some direct job creation component
in them and there's scores of them uh
most unevaluated of course some are
valued though but but you kind of look
at them all together and you say like
what are they trying to do here where's
the coordination and where the where are
the the synergies between them I don't
think anybody's thinking about that
okay well that's an important area then
for improvement
um I would like to turn it now over to
uh participants in the class for uh any
questions that our panelists can answer
Hobby
so uh I understand the broader I guess
inclination to have Economic Development
departments redirect our budget towards
like housing or education if that is
going to be more effective for Workforce
but I guess for the context of our
project right we're trying to advise
Economic Development agencies maybe some
more on this short term with regards to
our recommendations I know Dr Bart if
you wrote in your book that around like
six percent of the 50 billion dollar
economic benefits are dedicated towards
service oriented programs thinking about
like manufacturing extension small
business advisory so if we were to give
these cities that advice um let's spend
more money on one to many types of
services
is there a benchmark or some type of
like I don't number or another city that
they should look towards in terms of
evaluating their own budget and saying
hey we're spending X dollars in cash
incentives we probably want to spend
maybe instead of you know six percent
like 10 or 20 like how can we be
directed with that short-term
reallocation of resources and then the
second part of that question is for
cities that don't have the capability to
do that would you just recommend hiring
up
well I don't know if I have a magic
number to give you because I honestly
don't think there's any place that has
an ideal policy in the U.S I guess I
would be pushing
uh whatever cities you're working with
uh
let's find out what first of all the
situation is with respect to things like
zoning a business business sites uh let
me let's look about the key factors of
production you know we have land and
labor for example
is land available for business
development that is attractive to
business that is zoned for business and
that people can get into production
quickly or is that not true in your city
if you haven't gotten land available for
development why are you even doing
anything because you know you're not
gonna be able to get anywhere
uh and then labor you need to talk to
business this is where I think you know
people overdo the cluster stuff but but
talking to clusters of business and
related Industries about
what's local Community College like
are the programs they have for training
in your industry any good
are they well designed are they suited
to what your needs are what kind of
training needs might that industry have
do we need to maybe hire a more
specialized Factor do we need to work
out a procedure where the local
community college that we can figure out
a funding stream to buy specialized
equipment that could be used in training
right
um and that small business advice when
you talk to small businesses in the area
talk to smaller employers
do they find they can readily get
business advice from either a
manufacturing extension service Small
Business Development Center etc etc so I
don't have a magic formula for habit I
would push to make sure what you're
doing in those areas is adequate and if
you want to know how I'd pay for it I
would pay for it by say restricting the
term of incentives and saying let's let
let's make them no longer than five
years and let's uh uh that would help
pay for some of this and uh you know now
ultimately I think state and federal
policy will have to encourage better I
mean be honest with you I think the
ultimate solution of this uh would be if
the federal government decide to
regulate this to some extent the way the
European Union does but uh uh I think
it's actually I I I I think area it's in
their interest to reform on their own
but we need some Federal Regulation at
some point
any thoughts about that from
David or Becky
not that specific now yeah not as not as
specific a couple of a couple of related
thoughts though so one is
um obviously like I think what you're
saying is they can't change revenue
streams or things like that but is there
some ability that a local developer
would have economic developer would have
to actually
say look let's try and take some portion
of this Revenue stream and use it to
solve some of the frictions that we
think are really affecting what's
happening in that jurisdiction so let's
try some Transportation type of pilot
and see if we have like a I mean this is
kind of a wild idea of a Throwdown like
have like a you know uh same type of bus
system that like the Facebook employees
had or other employees had to try to get
employees from where they are to a
different to the and you know Industrial
Development
um area like is there some way that they
can use some of their you know take some
of the revenues to do that and solve
those problems and see if it helps with
the workforce participation I think the
other thing that's really important is
who are who are the companies that are
are getting incentivized and getting
actually receiving the incentives so one
concern is that if if incentives are
continued to be given to kind of you
know low-wage jobs is it somehow
trapping employees in those low-wage
jobs are there different types of
companies that they would rather obtain
or rather attract to their area now
that's a really really hard problem to
solve but it comes with overall higher
wages and maybe potentially different
spillover benefits in the local
community so I think there's a lot of
question around when an incumbent comes
to them that's already there that maybe
doesn't have the wage requirements that
they want do they actually re-up and
give incentives to that incumbent or do
they think more carefully about holding
back those incentives or giving lower
amounts of incentives and trying to
really use the dollars better for some
other company that they want to bring to
the area
I just say I'm not sure this is so much
response to the question but to what
Becky said California compete does pay
attention to wages and they pay
attention to wages relative to the local
labor market so a call center job in San
Francisco might not get any good funding
but a call center job in the Central
Valley which is much more like the
southeast United States that might be
viewed as a pretty good jobs relative to
what they have and receive funding
okay other questions yeah Ryan
yeah so we talked a lot about how to
attract uh companies and thus jobs to
maybe economically distressed areas but
if you think about some of those
communities maybe being underserved by
consumer-oriented businesses like
classic example groceries and food
deserts how do you think about
attracting businesses that would
increase the quality of life to a
certain area that maybe is not otherwise
an attractive investment
see I think of that as being Community
Development more than Economic
Development okay and and I think of that
as being important because I think
amenities in a neighborhood are
important and that includes things like
whether a grocery store is there and
that certainly can be part of what you
do but of course the Dilemma you face is
that if you improve amenities an area
without also upping the earnings per
capita of residents of the area then you
run into the whole gentrification issue
so I honestly think one key thing you
need to do in thinking about
neighborhood development that we don't
do enough of because the way we fund it
in the U.S neighborhood development the
U.S at the federal level is funded
through HUD Hud's more of a housing and
and physical infrastructure type
Improvement agency they don't they're
not particularly focused on job training
and job development Labor Department
doesn't really think in these
neighborhood terms that much and uh so
you need to somehow uh think about
neighborhood plans to not only make
amenity improvements like getting
grocery stores there but what are you
doing to actually help people never get
jobs or like Becky mentioned helping
with with transportation is very one
very simple thing
uh one common reason people either can't
get a job or lose a job is they have a
old car and it breaks down and they
can't afford to get it fixed
can you set up a program onto which
people can quickly get
uh low-cost loans to get their car fixed
right
and uh for a lot of people in the
neighborhood that could be a key factor
in determining whether you can get a job
and whether you can retain a job and so
my view would be if you're really trying
to help people in the neighborhood don't
just improve amenities in the
neighborhood also increase earnings per
capita more directly yeah I I I have a
maybe a similar reaction stronger put
I'm you know I think we're finally
learning at least to some extent whether
cities will will you know simulate this
information or not as an open question
uh how to make these policies work
somewhat better
um
I'd be disinclined to say let's let's
think about the more direct thing the
more indirect things I should say like
amenities
labor Supply might be an issue I agree
but but I kind of feel like some of
those things will follow from job
creation uh and might be a very
expensive way to create jobs
as opposed to going after job creation
directly but in David if I could just
you know in in your in your California
competes work I mean how do you know
that these are actual new jobs as
opposed to people's coming from other
places
um we well we we can we don't know well
okay so so
um
for the uh
uh the the track level stuff for
residents we we don't know that
necessarily
um for the firm level stuff we can see
you know what's going on at the firm
level versus at that specific location
and we can actually do a little bit of
work in that I wouldn't say it's super
informative but a question we haven't
gotten into at all except with this
Tim's allusion to National regulation
whether they're coming from other states
uh and it doesn't look like they are it
looks like um you know you're actually
sort of lowering the cost of doing
business and and that's causing
employment to actually grow but it's
hard to get at the director there aren't
many studies in this literature that
really get at that directly there's some
studies in France where they actually
got access attack tax records so they
can sort of track all the people at all
the establishments of a business as well
as new businesses and they found a lot
of evidence moving businesses and I just
read a paper for India where it's kind
of from a worker survey where people say
why they moved and there's a lot of
migration to new jobs among men and
interestingly among women migration
because my husband got it my husband's
I'm sorry I'm not immigration migration
because my job moved and among the women
migration because my husband's job moved
um so we do see that in some cases and I
don't know we see it that clearly here
but to my point about
um
uh the distressed neighborhoods you know
it's not neces it's better if it's all
new new employment you know de novo
across the whole economy
um but if we're trying to go after
distressed neighborhoods you know if if
uh if Silicon Valley had somewhat fewer
jobs and a low-income area had somewhat
more jobs the same number same jobs
especially that might well be in that
game because of externalities that come
from from job creation in more
distressed neighborhoods right yeah so
your point is that now now that we are
actually knowing something about we do
actually know something about maybe how
to structure these incentives uh to be
effective to improve job quality go in
that direction rather than these more
blanket programs like okay we're gonna
do you know some infrastructure project
that's going to generally sort of
improve what life here is like but might
not be might not have the targeted
results that that's your that's that's
kind of your statement so carefully
there probably are some smart things to
do on that ladder on that ladder side
but I think you need to be careful
because a lot of it would be very in
direct spending yes
there are a couple I mean I don't know
the
Tim and David you might know a little
bit more about these other incentives
but there are some incentives
um for things like uh retail space or
downtown refurbishment or things like
that so it's not exactly getting to what
your question is which is like how do I
get like a Whole Foods to show up in the
neighborhood but I know that there are
some movements to Grand incentives in
places like to try to revive old
downtowns and things like that I don't
know how effective those are my
impression is that these are businesses
that had already agreed to kind of come
and now they're going to get some
incentive just for doing maybe some
rehab they already would have but I
don't know of any good evidence on on
those incentives but it might be
something that's more in the area of
what you're trying to think about which
is providing some type of services or
infrastructures or cafes to the workers
who are coming
thank you
Sarah Whole Foods and low-income
neighborhood is probably not going to
solve a problem we heard it yesterday we
heard a uh an example yesterday of uh a
70 tax abatement to bring a a grocery
store into a food desert type of area I
mean that seems like something that's
well very targeted oh it might happen I
mean that I live in Kalamazoo the north
side of Kalamazoo is a low-income
neighborhood and it was a food desert or
in the city uh helped subsidize a
grocery store to locate there so people
would have better access to food at
somewhat lower prices
uh I don't know exactly what the subsidy
was and whether it was just through
property taxes I don't recall at the top
of my head or they did some kind of tax
to increment financing again I think we
need the distinguish between economic
and Community Development they're
different things uh Economic Development
deals with increasing the overall number
of jobs in a local labor market as well
way of boosting employment rates and
real wage rates of workers in that local
labor market Community Development deals
with trying to improve amenities and the
quality of life in particular
neighborhoods or as a way of hopefully
making them more attractive places you
want to make the downtown more
attractive or make this neighborhood
more attractive I think those are
important policies but they have very
different goals for what economic
development programs are trying to do
looks like Sarah had a question
thank you um we've heard a lot of
interest around government procurement
policies as levers for economic
development just in terms of job
creation and small business support
curious on your thoughts on those
especially as they pertain to targeting
more diverse populations or under
certain meetings
like what kind of government procurement
policies I'm curious what you mean
what's a congress I mean I realize
you're not supposed to mention specific
cities but what would be is can you give
an example of that revealing the name of
the city of a procurement policy who is
the target of that and how much money is
involved
so I think it's more process based so
for example at rfps for local
governments prioritizing or setting
photos for bypoc owned businesses
well I certainly think it'd be it's I
mean I think on the margin that trying
to help some locally owned businesses
although I personally would stress more
let's provide uh you know business
incubator space let's provide help in uh
business advice and help in the business
starting up you don't want the business
necessarily to be a business that is
dependent on having a quota and can't
really survive on its own in the market
long term I mean uh not that so I would
I would urge that you have active
programs uh that help provide services
to encourage the growth of businesses it
actually could be seen as a type of job
training program I mean you know it's
some people want to get a job where they
work for others other people want to
start their own business and and just as
there's a rationale for the government
providing job training assistance to
people who can't afford to pay for
training themselves there's a rationale
for the government providing
entrepreneur preneurial training to
people who want to start businesses and
that can certainly be something you want
to Target at distressed neighborhoods
and people in those neighborhoods
so with apologies to any remaining
questions we have to end to be mindful
of the time of our experts I want to
thank all of you very very much for
being here Tim Becky and David and for
sharing the insights of your research
and for a great conversation and we are
signing off for now thanks everyone
thank you keep up thank you thank you
bye bye